Etiquette states that you can receive and give your name card with one hand.
Especially, you find that in Americans, they don't give their name cards with two hands.
They usually give it out with one hand only.
And it is not even at the beginning of an acquaintance, it could be at the end...
...or sometimes in the middle.
But when you give or receive your name card with two hands,...
...it actually means that you're very well-mannered.
And read the designation, maybe even, whether they have an e-mail address or direct contact,...
...'cause you need all of these to follow up with your clients.
'Cause if you don't have, let's say, a mobile phone,...
...that's printed on the name card,...
...you might find it difficult to reach this person.
And you might want to even find out if you can have their mobile number,...
...but you have to ask nicely.
"I noticed that you didn't place your cellphone number."
"Is it possible for me to reach you other than your direct office number?"
So that people don't feel that you have an agenda.
"Why do you want my cellphone number? For what?"
But rather, "If I cannot reach you at your direct office line,..."
"...is there another number that I could reach you?"
That would be a very nice favor.